what we want to do now is apply a
similar process to think about the
vertical
motion so if you go back up to here you
can see here
this is the differential equation that
i've been presented with and instead of
x double dots and x dots i'm going to
get y double dots and y
dots right so i'm going to as promised
nudge you
in the right direction i'm going to say
okay let's consider the vertical motion
considering vertical motion
and maybe you're ahead of me at this
point uh and that's totally fine maybe
you can catch up for the next bit or i
can catch up for the next bit rather
what i'm going to do is just write that
differential equation first y double dot
equals uh
minus g minus k y dot so
that was the second derivative from the
left hand side and there's that first
derivative
in there for velocity i'm going to put
in my values for g
and for k and i think we said gravity
was 10
and then i had a fifth 4k so that gives
me
this equation now at this moment when
you have a look at this right i wonder
how many of you are scratching your
heads and thinking okay what does this
lead to
right what result am i going to get out
of this if i do just a little bit of
rearrangement maybe i'll be able to make
it clear to you
how this is a parallel between this
situation in vertical motion
and the situation we're looking at for
horizontal motions so
what i'm going to do is just a bit of
factorizing here so if i take out a
factor of
negative a fifth what am i going to get
here i'm going to put
that y dot out the front because you can
see a negative fifth just comes out of
that cleanly
the negative is easy to pull out but if
i'm pulling out a fifth as well then
this thing wants to become five times
bigger
on the inside so i'm just going to get
that and just as one final step which i
know may look a little like why are you
doing this mr wu
i'm going to write this as a difference
rather than as a sum so i'm going to
write it like
so okay so this is my equation for y
double dot for the vertical acceleration
now i want you to look closely at this
and if i zoom out enough maybe you can
see this at the same time
as oh it's going to get really small i
apologize for that just there i think
you might just be able to make it out
right
i want you to compare and i'll highlight
it for you just to make it super obvious
this differentialization equation here
which i got from y
and i want you to compare it with this
differential equation that i got from
x so i'm comparing horizontal and
vertical
now i want you to tell me if you can
post it in the chat if you're if it's
coming into your mind
what is the similarity and what is the
difference right and of course you know
you can see i've already put in that
minus
k there is this minus a fifth here so
it's remarkably similar so i want you to
tell me
if you can in the chat tell me what is
the same and what
is different and therefore what result
am i going to get for trying to get out
of a differential equation
get into something that i can integrate
any takers you want to suggest what's
similar
and what needs to be adjusted this one's
a little less obvious
any takers or you know what i just as
likely in fact not just as likely i'd
really love if you're confused you're
like i don't know i'm not looking i'm
not seeing it i'm not seeing a
comparison
just please post don't know like usually
i get to look at your faces and i can
see this sort of glazed look or a bit of
confusion
but then you can see that right now so
do me a favor give me some feedback tell
me like i've got nothing well here is my
idea that would be really valuable to me
actually because it'll
change the way i teach the rest of this
lesson okay
so i've got some suggestions from
angered and one from giu
is it a graph shift is that first
question
um joe is suggesting it's also
exponential decay but it's got this
extra constant
so this is really promising right um you
can see
and i sort of clued you into the fact
that i was writing in this awkward way
with this um you know it's a sum why
turn an addition into
two negatives right um if you say for
example were to consider let's pop it
over
the side here the difference between y
equals x squared
and y equals x minus 2
or squared right this is a graph
shift right the kind of angular has
identified in this case it would be
a horizontal shift of two units because
it's attached to the x
right over here i'm having a shift of
negative 50 and i've put that negative
50 in there to indicate the direction
right just like here it's negative uh
that minus
means two units but it's not going to go
to the left it's going to go to the
right
this is going to go not up but but down
so this is
something that we need to uh need to be
considering right
now it is as jr you said also
exponential decay you can see
essentially
it's the same thing there's an x double
dot
and multiply by constant x dot and the
same thing down here like if i just kind
of
hid this away let me see if i can do
this reasonably if i just made this
disappear
right ta-da exponential decay right so
putting that back
accounts for this shift so here's what
i'm going to suggest
this is my nudge and then i'm going to
give you like i don't know maybe five or
six minutes
um you guys will indicate to me whether
you need more time okay i want to say
out of this
is that i can draw the same conclusion
that i had earlier on from an
exponential decay
point of view that since this is going
to be an exponential decay situation i
can say
it's going to be b e to the negative t
on 5. i've picked a different letter i
chose a before so i can't use it again
because it might not be the same and
that's going to be
shifted how far is it going to be
shifted answer
50 units and i get that directly from
here
now some of you are going to look at
that and say mr i do not see that at all
that is not
obvious to me um and for those of you
who are feeling like that
um i've actually just earlier today i
made a video to answer that exact
question like
how can you pull this rabbit out of a
hat move if you don't immediately
recognize that that is exponential decay
with a shift it's considerably longer i
think it takes takes me like 11 or 12
minutes to fully explain it and do it
from first principles you can
integrate a few times actually to show
it but
i'm going to leave that as something
that some of you will be content not to
watch because you're like i can see it
straight away
and then if you want that later you're
welcome to watch it um i've literally
got my
mouse over the save button on the canvas
page where it's going to reveal the link
for you
but it's not there yet so here's what
i'm going to ask you to do and like i
said five or six minutes for this
i've gotten you uh like halfway to
getting the
um vertical displacement equation
in terms of time uh we were asked for x
as a function of time
and uh y as a function of time we've got
this one
and i've got you halfway there for this
what i'd like you to do is see if you
can finish off my working to get y as a
function of time
and then once you have these two
parametric equations these two time
equations
what we want to do is eliminate the
parameter get rid of the t you're gonna
have to substitute either the
x equation and some of its results into
y or
vice versa i'll let you have a think
about which one might be more useful
and once you can eliminate t you will
have done this
determine the cartesian equation of
motion
so if you are able to successfully do
that i'll put this back on screen so you
can see we're all on the same starting
point here there's your y dot
i am trying to get to a y equals all
right so
i think i'm going to pick up from there
i'm seeing some answers coming into the
chat which is very promising
so let's see if we can land the plane
actually that was a different question
um this is about
what is this about i can't remember it i
don't think it's got a plane uh it's
just a projectile being fired okay it's
trying to get the plane to take off
um we are going to pick up from where we
had this line
here which was our velocity equation
with respect to time
and you can see what i've done is i've
used my initial condition t equals zero
um i've popped in and i've gotten from
that initial vector that the
the vertical velocity was 30 at the
instant when the projectile was fired
so that gives me once i evaluate out
that
that coefficient there of the
exponential term is going to be 80.
i'll pop that back in and now i'm ready
to integrate so just like i integrated
x dot with respect to time i integrate y
dot with respect to time
you end up with this and you look at
this mess and you think
what is this it's very strange but we
can actually still work with it because
when you put in t equals 0
we defined the origin as our point where
we were firing the projectile from
so if you have a careful look here right
you're going to get
0 over here this term is going to become
1 so you get a negative 400 um this term
is also going to become 0. so
you've got the negative 400 and the
constant over here so
if you add 400 to both sides that will
give you
constant 2 and i had to name it
separately because of my other constant
up above
so there you go there is my equation my
parametric
equation for a vertical displacement
with respect
to time